what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so this story is like the greatest
Batman story ever told really it's like
a Batman Superman story but it's like
the greatest story ever told I love this
story so much now I mean I haven't read
everything about Batman so I guess maybe
it's not I guess I can't really say it's
a greater story ever told but oh the
stories I've read it's like the best
Batman story ever told it's so cool
because this is all about like bromance
between Batman and Superman as well as
like Catwoman and Lois Lane okay what
would be the woman equivalent of a
bromance like I don't know what the
woman equivalent that is like oh oh woe
manse I guess I don't know like maybe
there's friends I don't know like like
BFFs I have no idea like with you what
the equivalent of that is but it is cool
because like like initially this kind of
kicks off with like Superman and Lois
Lane kind of going back and forth right
and the whole reason why is because Lois
Lane is like you should call Batman
like we need to hang out like we need to
like get together and like we need to
like hang out and have some fun and just
like have like an adult's night out
because like it would be fun and it's
kind of funny because like Superman
avoids it right he's just kind of like
oh I'm busy you know I've got I've got
stuff you know that I've got to do you I
mean I've got you know superhero things
like it's just making up reasons for why
you can't call Batman and at the same
time Batman does the same thing right I
mean Catwoman and Batman are facing off
against some guys you know and it's like
well you should call Superman like like
you know he's like the best friend you
have like we need to hang out we got to
get together and that's was kind of
funny about this is like when it comes
to the way these stories are done you
have like Lois Lane and Catwoman who
kind of stand in as the voice of reason
and we wouldn't normally expect it to be
that way right like we've been expected
to be like Batman and Superman who were
like the voices of reason but are there
like two guys who just can't bring
themselves to call each other because
it's all kind of based on pride and all
that kind of stuff but as this goes on
it kind of begins to sort of Windell
things down to where we get to like the
heart of the matter of why they won't
necessarily call each other I mean Lois
Lane wants to meet Catwoman and like
Catwoman wants to meet Lois Lane and so
really to kind of like bring the two
together sort of going through their
husbands it's really funny you know
because when it comes to like Lois Lane
she just dances look you know I've
looked in the Catwoman you know I've
looked into what she's about you know
I've looked into who she is as a villain
basically like Selina Kyle and I'm I'm
curious about her like I want to know
what would lead a person Tim to want to
marry Batman I want to know what level
of insanity would drive a person to that
cloth I need to know why this is the
case and again it is fun because we
would kind of expect it as you know
Superman is gonna be like okay cool
let's let's call
let's see what's up like listen let's
get together but once we start to go
through in these little mix and crannies
you're these these little tidbits these
little small things it's sort of make
these characters who they are what we
end up finding out is like Batman and
Superman in a lot of ways idolize each
other like I mean you know you got a
Superman fighting against some radiation
guy you know I don't really know his
name I don't really care enough to look
it up but you got Superman fighting some
radiation guy you've got Batman going
against this various group you know and
really these roads are kind of leaving
them to each other but it's not really
the villains they're facing it's not
that's not the important part of this
the important part of this is that they
sort of highlight the other's existence
they highlight the other's purpose the
role they play they highlight who they
are and what they're about when it comes
to Batman he sits down and he simply
says boil Eastwood Catwoman speculates
it says that you're ashamed of me of
course Batman's responses of course not
that's crazy talk I am not ashamed of
you at all that would land me in the
doghouse if I said yes even if I was
joking but still from Batman's
perspective he almost see Superman is
like a better man than him and that's
what's so interesting about this but at
the same time Superman sees Batman as a
better man than him each one puts the
other on a pedestal and that's what so
why this was so cool about this because
all they really see are like the great
aspects of each other now that's just a
hallmark of having a friendship it stood
the test of time for so long I mean
that's really kind of the thing that
goes into all this is that you've got
Superman and Batman who were like the
one-two punch of DC Comics and they've
been neato they've been enemies they've
been friends all those things but all
that has kind of built up over the years
into this tried and true friendship
that's had its ups and downs but each
one respects the other to such a degree
that they don't really see the flaws and
the other person I mean they know
they're there but they don't really look
at those aspects they look at what makes
them great Batman is is the detective
he's like one of the smartest man if not
the smartest man I would argue that
maybe Lex Luthor is a little bit smarter
depending on what circumstance were
talking about but by and large like mr.
terrific Batman Lex Luthor had like the
top three spots but still in the eyes of
Batman Superman is like the hero he's
the good guy like he's the boy scout and
even if Batman will give him a hard time
over it there's respect found in that
there's respect found in the idea that
Superman will put all others above
himself and Batman will too but where
Batman is kind of like the dark and
brooding side of role really of like a
singular person Superman is kind of like
the uplifting side that's the cool thing
about this you juxtapose these people
you put them into like one
and then suddenly like they're just two
sides of any one individual person they
keep each other balanced and they keep
each other grounded and so what is up
happening is that the villas they face
basically lead them to like one
particular building and they take two
different Evert entrances to get in
there Batman sneaks in because you know
he's Batman like that's what you do when
you're Batman you don't just walk in the
front door that's crazy talk if Batman
we're gonna go grocery shopping for
example Batman would not go to like you
know Kroger's and like walk in the front
door he would like jump on top of the
building and like sneak down feel like
the ductwork and then like sneak around
and get what he wants and then like
swipe his bat credit card and be out
before anybody knows he's there but like
when you're Superman you like yeah man
we gotta go grocery shopping because
we're low on lettuce you know and like
you you go in there and you buy the
stuff you need and then you leave like a
normal human being does but still like
they end up running into each other and
it is kind of funny because what ends up
happening is like they're kind of
standoffish right like well I didn't
expect to see you here Batman
you know and maybe have like Selina Kyle
and Lois Lane and Lois Lane's like you
must be Catwoman it's nice to meet you
and like they immediately break the ice
and start shaking hands now of course
these villains show up and of course
they make quick work out of them but
Superman's response is well let's get
some dinner this is where the story gets
amazeballs
it gets so cool they show up to the
Gotham County Fair and it's superhero
night now I'm gonna be honest with you
guys I've been to a lot of fairs all
right I'm into a lot of fairs a lot of
carnivals in my time I have never seen a
carnival or fair where's like you can't
get in here unless your address is a
superhero I really want to go to one of
these anyway when these guys get in here
it's kind of funny because they're
immediately turned away right they're
like hey look it's superhero night you
have to be a superhero if you're not
dressed as a superhero you can't come in
here and they don't believe they're
superheroes even though this guy is
talking to Batman and Superman Lois Lane
and Catwoman have this genius idea
whether they're like well let's just
switch costumes Batman can be Superman
and Superman can be Batman and like I
Lois Lane will be like like Catwoman and
it's like the most beasts idea ever
right because like the whole time
Batman's like no we're not doing this
and we're we're not we're not doing this
all right we're not switching into
costumes we're not trading places we're
not doing any of this stuff we're just
gonna sit and be sad because like I'm
Batman that's what I do
I'm mope and so like you guys know it
that man mopes
but still like the funny thing is that
we're we're Batman's adverse to it all
Catwoman's like whoa you guys
misunderstand what he's saying
when he says no when he says no what he
means is that he knows his fiancee is
really hungry and she's being very
patient right now
but her patience is running out very
very fast and he recognizes he needs to
remedy that and so he's going to do that
aren't you Batman because it's in your
best interest to do that and so like
they do as any married man will tell you
if the wife ain't happy ain't nobody
happy and so it's funny because like
they basically switch costumes and like
the whole time this happens it looks so
amazing like it's so cool because you've
got Batman who's cheery and Superman
who's just like mopey you know like like
I'm just gonna call him Batman suit
right now I'm gonna confuse the heck out
of you guys but you got like Bruce Wayne
Superman who's just like this is not
going to be fun but I mean look at this
it's like the most fun ever like you're
eating corn dogs and like Lobo is doing
the Hammer machine thing that like like
people always fail out and they feel bad
I mean it's cool with this thing because
I think going to the tunnel of love and
it's like it's like a married couple
versus a a newlywed couple Clark Kent
and Lois Lane come out it's this is so
weird to me like seeing them like this
Clark Kent and Lois Lane coming out
they're like well that was nice man
Bruce Wayne - Selina Kyle come out and
they're just they're going at it like
rabbits and heat it is it's amazing but
the best part of this is the batting
cage right when they get to the batting
cage they're just like smacking
baseball's left and right and then
Superman is like hey man I mean I could
pitch to you if you want like you
wouldn't hit it but I mean I could pitch
to you if you want and then Batman's
like nah dude
like if you pitch to me Superman I would
smash that baseball like you don't have
a chance like there's really nothing you
could do here like I would absolutely
smash I think something else also want
you guys to notice - Superman is dressed
as Batman wearing his glasses I think
it's hilarious I think it's amazing
Batman wearing glasses Batman weren't
specs - dad this is this is like the
most fun I've ever had covering a story
before this is amazing but the other
half of this is like like we pick up
with Lois Lane and Catwoman right and
this is this is this is cool because for
the most part again like they're foreign
entities to each other to a degree and
the biggest question that that Lois Lane
has is like why Batman like of all the
people you could marry why would you
marry Batman and the answer of Catwoman
is so simple and it's so amazing and
it's beautifully done her response is
it's just because he catches me when I
fall and as ennis you know the questions
like like can you relate to that and
it's it's so cool because
like that's the story of Superman and
Lois Lane and we've said it a million
times before Lois Lane Falls Superman
catches her but it's that he's always
there for her and she's always there for
him it is the definition of what it
means to be like a tried and true
partner you know try to Dru luck I mean
that's kind of the nature of life right
I mean when people get together and
people get in relationships they're not
really waiting on Superman right I mean
like like a lot of women out there
aren't really waiting on Superman to
show up and whisk them away from all the
dangers of the world and to give them
all the money they need so they never
have to worry about things I mean there
are some who are but like by and large
if a woman out there is waiting on
Superman is because she's superwoman
she's looking for a partner she's not
looking for a superhero white knight to
show up and rescue her from all of
life's struggles you know the idea of a
relationship is coming across problems
and solving them together and that's why
this works is because the relationship
between Selina Kyle and Batman is
juxtaposed right next to the
relationship between Lois Lane and
Superman and where we would think they
would be starkly different and where we
would think it would all be predicated
on two completely diametrically opposed
views instead they're the exact same
everybody's looking for the same thing
everyone is looking for love and where
Lois Lane and Superman found it Selina
Kyle and Batman have found it but it's
one of those things where like when you
cut below the personality of Gotham when
you cut below the whole you know I'm
putting this wall up because I'm Batman
and this walls here because I protect
myself from the world when you cut past
all that and when you cut past you know
Selina Kyle he does the same thing there
does to people looking for love and they
found it in each other and that's why
this is so beautiful and that's why this
is so cool now from here like it's kind
of funny because as they're walking
along this guy dresses the question runs
up and snatches the purse of Lois Lane
and it's hilarious because it's like the
question is it who's going to let me the
question is who is going to stop me and
is this it's hilarious honestly if I saw
this like if I were at like this
superhero themed comic book him or
another yeah I guess like a comic book
convention at a theme park like if I
were there and I saw this I would try to
get it like I would try to record it and
like I would upload it as a front bumper
on my channel I'd be like guys you have
to see this you know and they're like I
would put it in the video but like
people would love it and it would be
amazing and I would just be like yes yes
all those likes I am feasting on them
but like it would be it'd be hilarious
because in response to all this Superman
and Batman are just kind of watching
this happen and then like like
Superman's like okay so like here's how
far
this guy is how fast he's traveling and
that man's like God it throws a baseball
knocks the dude right out and somebody
dresses green Lancer is just kind of
like damn also maybe it's just me that
guy looks like he's dressed as Alan
Scott Green Lantern oh my god they're
reversing Alan Scott Green Lantern like
the old Alan Scott now the new Alan
Scott the new Alan Scott's not as good
as you old one the old Alan Scott
but once that eye starts to wind down
like once everything starts to come to a
close and it really starts to come to an
end it's really more or less everybody
just saying hey look this was amazing
like this was this was a great time you
know I had a blast Batman is just kind
of like no I did not have fun even
though I did I'm just not going to tell
you like like I mean that's that's
brooding Batman but you know when the
whole thing winds down is funny because
the Superman is like hey man like I'd
still love to like pitch at you sometime
to like throw a baseball and see if you
can hit it you know I mean you can't but
like I mean we'll see what's up you
knows like I know a place so they end up
at like a baseball pitch right and this
this is a cool this is a coolest thing
ever we end up at a baseball pitch and
like Superman goes to throw the baseball
and Batman's like dude um I'm gonna hit
it I mean that's just the way it is you
know and Superman is like whatever man
nobody can hit this baseball like you're
not gonna hit this baseball Batman and
Superman throws the ball and he's like
here's to the impossible and in the
comic games we never find out what
happens that's not true
I don't know why I told you that what is
it happening his Batman smashes it why
because he has tripped on who that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explain make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]